before you go into the room with your
user you'll want to figure out exactly
how you want to record data from your
interaction generally speaking you have
three options you can take notes
directly which is the easiest to get
used to agree to and does a really good
job of allowing you to pull out the
things that sound important to you in
the moment writing notes also means that
you don't need to take time later on to
sift through the feedback again you can
also ask for permission to record the
audio of the conversation in the next
video we'll introduce you to the concept
of talk aloud which will be key to user
research and also allow you to get great
feedback through the voice of your user
this is great because it allows you to
focus on the testing as it's going on
and sift through the data later
additionally you'll often catch really
useful snippets of things you did right
nothing convinces investors quite so
much as hearing user be verbally excited
about your app design as they're
interacting with it nothing that is
except for seeing that user be excited
about interacting with the app if you
have the resources and are able to get
permission it can be really useful to
record video of both the prototype as
users interacting with it and the users
face as they're interacting with the
prototype this footage takes a while to
sift through and so is mainly
appropriate for higher fidelity
prototypes later on but can be really
useful in presentations to investors I
would suggest that for the sake of the
first prototype you just take notes it's
always vital to have a record but for
the moment we're wanting to get feedback
as fast as possible